while here police have arrested four  people after a video appearing to show  anti-semitic language being shouted from  a  convoy of cars in central london footage  shared on social media showed the  vehicles covered in palestinian flags  with those inside appearing to shout  offensive and threatening language  [Music]  the arrested men were detained on  suspicion of racially aggravated public  order offences  in a tweet prime minister boris johnson  said there's no place for anti-semitism  in our society  ahead of shavat i stand with british  jews who should not have to endure  this type of shameful racism we've seen  today  whilst the labour leader shakir starma  tweeted that the video is  utterly disgusting anti-semitism  misogyny and hate have no place  on our streets or in our society there  must be consequences